schauen Sie mal dann erkläre ich Ihnen das mal
kurz das hier ist unsere nutzen Kostenanalyse der
Neubau der A20 einem der größten autobahnprojekte
das Deutschland derzeit haben sehen Sie hier läuft
sie ungefähr entlang nein so um festzustellen ob
diese Autobahn überhaupt Wirtschaft ist teilen
wir den erwarteten Nutzen hier oben durch den die
erwarteten Kosten und wenn das Ergebnis größer als
eins ist diese Straße wirtschaftlich haben sie
das soweit verstanden ja ich befürchte ja das
heißt bei ihnen wird jedes Projekt durchgewunken
solange der nutzen nur ein Cent höher ist das hier
erwarteten Kosten ja in der Tat schreiten wir zur
selbigen hier machen wir erstmal die die Kosten
die erwarten für Bau und Planung der Autobahn das
sind 5,7 Milliarden Euro ja wie kommen Sie denn
auf diese Zahl nun der diese Zahl wird geschätzt
von von den Ländern sehen Sie und von uns wird
diese Zahl dann in der Regel sehr sorgfältig
übernommen also nicht ungeprüft wir nennen das
bürokratisch sehen Sie die Baukosten werden
ja von den Ländern in der Regel sehr sehr
sorgfältig also also absichtlich zu niedrig
angesetzt ja deswegen heißt es ja auch Tiefbau
skandalös wenn ich das der Presse erzähle
dann schlafen den die Füße ein sind sehr
Bundesrechnungshof beschwert sich schon
seit 20 Jahren darüber dass die Kosten
im Autobahnbau regelmäßig zu niedrig angesetzt
werden warum setzen Sie die Kosten denn leicht
nicht einfach höher an ich habe ihn dazu
erklärt wenn sich hier die Kosten größer
machen durch den Quotienten wird er hier unten
die Wirtschaftlichkeit kleiner wir setzen jetzt
noch erstmal den erwarteten Nutzen ein das
sind die Fahrzeit Gewinne von 2,5 Milliarden
2,5 Milliarden Ersparnis durch Fahrzeit Gewinne
der pendelt denn da zwischen Oldenburg und Stade
ilon Mast oder wie nein wir rechnen ungefähr so
er wir rechnen mit 19000 Fahrzeugen wenn die z.B
in 25 Jahren jeweils 10 Minuten Fahrzeit
einspannen dann haben wir etwa einer ist
das 375 Millionen Euro werden das macht die
Baukosten für 50 km Autobahn durchaus wieder
weg wir fahren das ganze quasi also wieder
rein wie das denn die unterstellen das den
Autofahrer Nähe Sparte Stunde 13 € wert ist und
noch dazu kommt natürlich nicht die Einsparung
durch weniger Betriebskosten mehr Sicherheit und
vergessen Sie nicht den impliziten nutzen implizit
das stimmt so nicht
das das mag ja ganz witzig sein aber natürlich
denken wir uns das nicht aus wir nehmen das an
also wir nehmen an dass jede zusätzliche
Fahrt automatisch ein Nutzen von etwa 34
Euro produziert sagen sie machen Sie in diesem
Haus eigentlich noch etwas anderes sich als ich
den fiktiven Nutzen von irgendwelchen Dingen
auszudenken stand endlich Maßnahmen gegen die
Klimakrise zu ergreifen wo sind denn ihre nutzen
Kostenanalyse eigentlich die entstehenden CO2
Emissionen die sind hier die ziehen wir natürlich
von dem besagten nutzen wieder ab 0,7 Milliarden
ah die Schäden für die Umwelt spielen bei ihnen
keine große Rolle warum sollten sie auch sind
sie die werden ja gleich wieder Reinhold von
dem positiven schauen Sie das ist ungefähr das
Verhältnis denn die quasi negativen nutzen werden
ja quasi kompensiert durch den positiven Nutzen
das ist bei all unseren straßengrunde sagen Sie
mal in welchem Universum kann man den CO2 durch
eine höhere Reisegeschwindigkeit ausgleichen
herzlich willkommen im Verkehrsministerium
ist ja auch egal ich war die Autobahn fällt bei
der Kosten Nutzenanalyse ja sowieso durch nein
nein nur wenn das Ergebnis aus dem Quotienten
aus Nutzen und Kosten kleine eins ist aber das
ist noch lange nicht gesagt wir haben die Rechnung
ja gar nicht fertig wir müssen erst um minus plus
habe ich schon kommt 0,9 raus also weniger als
eins die automatisch durchgefallen keine Geld
Feierabend machen bitte viel Spaß Moment warte
warte das war mein Fehler aber ein Moment so so
ist das viel besser Moment haben sie gerade die
Kosten der Autobahn von 5,7 auf 2,7 Milliarden
Euro reduziert nein haben sie schon oder Sie
haben es gemacht ich habe gesehen sie sind 5,7
ja das ist doch nur die aktuelle Kostenschätzung
des Ministeriums das hier ist die ursprüngliche
Kostenschätzung aus dem Ministerium heraus und
die ist doch die entscheidende weil dann sind
wir da hinten ungefähr bei 1,9 und damit größer
als aber wenn sie dir tatsächlich einen Kosten
nehmen dann ist der Wert der unter eins ich
habe da können wir die Straße ja nicht bauen
und das wäre ja mal schade
ja passen Sie aber bitte auf was sie machen da
fällt mir der Flachmann raus was sie auf da ist
ein more können Sie das nicht sehen passen Sie
auf das Moore ich habe das doch im Blick Mann gut
deswegen sagen Sie mal ihr großer Küsten durch
einen Moor das gefährdet wichtige CO2 Speicher
nein das Gegenteil ist der Fall sehen Sie
die CO2-Speicher gefährden unsere Straßen
aus dem regen sich jetzt doch nicht so auf wir
haben doch bereits eine Umweltprüfung gemacht
ja dann fällt die Straße jetzt durch ja naja
sagen wir so der gesamte Bundesverkehrswegeplan
erfüllt 11 von 12 selbst gesteckten Umwelt Zielen
nicht und warum werden diese Straßen da trotzdem
gebaut na dass die Straßen der Umweltschaden
das schmälert ja nicht ihr Nutzen sehen sie
ein Umweltprüfung kann in der Regel ja eine
neugebaute Autobahn gar nicht stoppen wenn
diese Autobahn als vordringlich gekennzeichnet
worden ist was ist an einer Straße durch ein
Naturschutzgebiet denn vordringlich ja gut dass
sie fragen die Raumwirkung aber der Raum wird
doch zerstört nein nein ganz im Gegenteil er
wird verbunden ja machen sie mal sehr schön
können wir gleich ausprobieren von einer guten
Raumwirkung geht man bei uns da aus wenn quasi
die verschiedenen Zentren in einem Raum ja hoch
qualitativ verbunden sind aber in Deutschland sind
doch alle Städte schon sehr gut verbunden aber
nicht wenn sie von der direkten Luftlinie als
Maßstab ausgehen welcher verrückte würde denn die
Luftlinie als Maßstab für den Straßenbau nehmen
herzlich willkommen im Verkehrsministerium nein
hören sie auf Himmel hier liegen doch überall
schon Straßen rum ja sie haben Recht da hilft
glaube ich nur noch eins eine Umgehungsstraße
unaufhaltsam das sagen uns all unsere
Prognosen wer erstellt denn diese
Prognosen privatwirtschaftliche
Planungsbüros die an der Planung
von straßenverdienen die wir bauen
aufgrund ihrer Prognosen wieso haben
sie wir brauchen doch diese Straße
sie sind doch selber was hier los ist
doch nur so viel los weil sie immer
neue Straßen bauen ja hier brauchen
wir eine neue Straße hör auf damit neue Straße
10 % mehr Straßenfläche bringt 10 % mehr Verkehr
was soll das sein eine Verschwörungstheorie von
Fußgängern nein das ist empirisch billigste
von der Mandel auf Highway kongression von
Anthony Downs wer war das ein Fußgänger gegangen
sein sie hört sie auf wie wollen Sie denn so die
Klimaziele erreichen das Bundesverfassungsgericht
sagt doch Klimaschutz ist ein Grundrecht ja da ist
es ja sehr gut dass wir dieses Rundschreiben
davon Minister missing der gesagt hat er die
Klimaziele dürfen den Autobahn ausfahren
das zeige ich Kanzler Scholz ja der hat
doch gar nichts davon ein Fahrzeug nimm mal am
besten machen sie gehen sie runter hier beim
Wagen ist beschlagnahmen so bilden sie eine
Rettungsgasse lassen Sie mich durch ich bin
Physiker warum geht er dir nicht vorwärts ach
was solls da ist doch gar keine Strafe danke
gegeben dass er die Klimaziele
ignorieren kann [Applaus]
hallo hier ja was vergessen
können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug